[Applause]
death came in rucksack sworn by these
men
striking churches and hotels within
minutes of each other some pictured on
their mobile phones possible evidence of
a wider network coordinating the attacks
turning the innocence of Easter Sunday
into scenes of terror
two days later Islamic state said it
carried out the bombings releasing this
video of suspects pledging allegiance to
its leader only one face is unmasked
Muhammad Hashim Muhammad that ran in his
early 30s a self-styled radical preacher
and the suspected ringleader who
targeted the shangri-la hotel with
another bomber the other seven men and
one woman involved are from different
parts of sri lanka they're largely well
educated well-traveled and with wealthy
families seven hours drive from Colombo
is the majority Muslim town at
hoody this is where Sauron was born into
a poor family the eldest of five friends
described him as an arrogant but
compelling orator with hardline views on
Islam but leaders of the Muslim
community a damning saying he was
expelled from religious College for
breaking rules excluded from a mosque
for lying some day mrs. a her aunt says
their extremism ideas then set up his
own group national towie Jamaat or ntj
in 2012 using it to criticize others
even those of his own faith who didn't
agree with him this is the National
towhee Jamaat mosque where's that one
used to preach before his interpretation
of Islam became too extreme for his
colleagues this letter sent by the ntj
Tuesday ran back in December 2017 was to
inform him that he's being expelled from
the organization inside the mosque is a
former friend who's now leader of the
mtj he claims are on only revealed he
was an is supporter through online posts
after fleeing the town in 2017 for
getting into a fight when he was talking
on Facebook they're saying this
Parliament is not good business and what
did he think when you first heard the
news that zaharan your old friend was
actually the supposedly leader of these
bombings so angry and I feel ashamed
kisara betrayed me it's been so much
time together and we started the ntj
together he's betrayed us were your
drones in Nigeria or in the body
mentality a couple of hours after
speaking with us mohamed tau feek was
arrested by police in a raid on the
mosque officials have linked the mtj and
another group to the attack he denies
the claim
Zara's grunting over the internet was on
the radar of Indian intelligence for his
radical views but wasn't hunted down by
Sri Lanka instead allowed to transform
into a suicide bomber resurfacing here
at the shangri-la hotel to kill a second
man Abdul Latif Jameel Mohammed age 36
studied engineering in the UK and did a
postgraduate in Australia he blew
himself up at a guest house pictured
looking at his phone posing as a guest
at the five-star Taj Samudra hotel abdul
latif smishing
didn't go to plan something went wrong
with the detonation charge on his
backpack bomb forcing him to leave
change clothes and retreat to the
outskirts of Colombo checking into the
low-grade tropical in then seen as he
tried to visit a mosque said to be
sympathetic with the ntj four hours
later Abdul Latif returned to the guest
house the second time he came aside he
was laughing he smiled a receptionist he
seemed relaxed he went to the room and
the receptionist heard him lock the door
around eight minutes later Kenda blasts
investigators believe he was trying to
fix the bomb when it went off killing
himself and two other guests reducing
this one-story building to rubble police
were already monitoring this son of a
tea trader from the central city of
candy Abdul Latif had two passports and
traveled widely including at least two
times to the UK possibly also trying to
reach Syria next to two sons of a
wealthy spice trader 35 year old
Muhammad Ibrahim in chef ahmed hit the
cinnamon Grand Hotel and his brother
Mohammad Ibrahim Ilhan Mohammed 32
struck the shangri-la a woman called
Fatima was married to one of the
brothers she died in a bomb blast during
a police raid on the family home in the
demo to go to suburb of Colombo Muhammad
Ibrahim is the head of the family a
respected businessman who owns a Shana
exports now under arrest as US agents
help the
Lankans examine his house this mayor has
been a friend of the deeply religious
family for decades he last spoke to the
father on Good Friday saying he seemed
normal
he went right up to now we can't imagine
how they became like this suicide
bombers because they I mean they had a
good wealth to live and they have a good
education and all that background with
we also can't understand what happened
really
the youngest son Ilhan Mohammed ran a
coffee making business on this street in
the capital where the father's company
logo can be seen other properties there
at a small Industrial Estate a short
drive away police have just come here to
lock up the families businesses
this was the warehouse where the father
kept a lot of his spices and across the
road is the copper factory that was run
by what it would brothers there's no
sign of the Bangladeshi workers who were
here just two days ago when I met them
they told me their boss the eldest son
was one of the Bombers in sup he's dead
I started coming the army I will see her
mobile for the dead bodies he was he was
a suicide bomber yes yes army told me
his suicide I said your boss must be so
shocking
the businesses meant the brothers often
traveled overseas at some point
developing extremist views also
seemingly held by one brothers wife who
lived at the family home she suspected
of killing herself her unborn child and
had two children in a blast during a
police raid after the main bombings
three officers died as well at least one
of the other Bombers was also from
Colombo Albertine Ahmed worth 22 is
perhaps the youngest of the gang
he attacked Sint Antony's church Sky
News has obtained this exclusive picture
of him he's thought to be from another
well-off family his driving license
addressed to this small plastics factory
which belonged to his father but is now
run by an uncle this man who works
opposite recognized my picture of the
bomber like white person
ready go go sir are you surprised yeah
little is yet known about what made such
a young man inflict such horror on so
many at this church two more bombers
have been named locally as mohammed
mubarak mohammed assam who hit the
Kingsbury hotel in colombo seen here
looking jittery just before pulling the
trigger and actually Muhammadu mohammed
who has two who carried out the
bloodiest of the bombings that sent
Sebastian's church in the town of
negombo he's pictured patting a girl on
the head as he strides towards his
target last is 34 year old mohammed
nazar muhammad as are from the same
hometown as the group's ringleader they
were friends he targeted a church in
nearby batterer Koloa this british
tracks his final seven and a half hours
at the top of the screen a bus carrying
Muhammad Azhar stops in eastern Sri
Lanka at just after 2:00 a.m. on Easter
Sunday a rickshaw gives him a ride to
bata Koloa an hour's drive away
he leaves the vehicle and walks to the
front gate of the mosque clutching two
bags at 5:42 am the gate of the jami
Acela mosque is opened Mohammed as our
works in leaving his deadly luggage
inside the building before joining
worshippers to pray seen here on the
right rolling up his tracksuit bottoms
slipping away early praying alone
between two plastic chairs then heading
outside in a change of t-shirt
speaking on the phone walking slowly
seemingly scoping the area around his
target it's now only minutes until the
first suicide bomb goes off in Colombo
he returns briefly to the mosque before
his final departure striding casually
stepping over a cordon on his way to
kill
images of the attackers illustrate the
coordination and training identical
rucksacks baseball caps to hide their
faces a change of clothes to conceal
their tracks pictured on their mobile
phones possibly receiving instructions
from someone else the deaths of these
bombers are by no means an end to the
threat a complex investigation now
underway looking at the group in the
wider network a raid last week uncovered
this bomb making kitten an is flag a
source told me that Iran may have
trained scores more bombers two of his
brothers pictured here and their father
blew themselves up after clashes with
the security forces more than a hundred
people have been arrested including this
man from Kat and Cody found with the
same kind of is robe and scarf as the
Bombers others remain at large
no one here believes that that man was
the mastermind of the Easter Sunday
bombings they say he must have had
outside help
but there was one unescapable fact this
small town will forever be linked with
one of the world's worst terrorist
attacks and suspicions remain that
others could do the same black and white
flags mourning the victims lined the
streets as the focus here turns to
reconciliation Muslim preachers
addressing a Catholic congregation
United in grief and condemnation hopeful
that time will heal
[Music]